("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
- What if I told you this was
the last Monday
morning of your life?
5:20 in the morning.
Just one of those things.
Heading out.
Trying to find
these crazy good shots
'cause I don't want people
giving DRock too much credit.
(laughs) Kidding, DRock.
Love you so much.
Figured I'd give
you guys an update.
Just been sitting here for the
last 4 1/2 hours doing email.
It's not super exciting or
interesting but obviously want
to give you guys context.
A lot of the work I have to
do that to my email
answering certain things.
Replying to
questions from the team,
setting up meetings,
cancelling meetings,
just saying hello to a pitch
or doing air traffic control of
where things go in my world is
done on flights so that's what
I'm doing.
Constant motion,
constant motion.
Always be moving.
I think that's such a
big factor in what I do.
You know, just landed
like second I land I get
internet connection and start
watching the new episode.
I gotta prove that for DRock.
20 to 6, Steelers.
I'm not watching any football.
I fucking hate
football right now.
Anyway, so instead of watching
football on the flight like
everybody else was,
I was working,
emails, hustling.
Second I landed
I watch the preview now.
Now, I'm jumping
in the car with Avi.
Tyler's here so we're gonna
create the meat of today's
episode 'cause it's a Sunday.
And just gotta get
home to family life and
so that's how we do it, man.
Speed matters, taking advantage
of every fucking second.
I don't think
people really get it.
I think people are confused
and if you're living that one
life and you got that ambition,
just make every second count.
Get efficient,
get super efficient.
Hack the seconds.
'Sup everyone?
Just landed from LA was
there for a couple hours,
couple meetings.
From Seattle, no footage.
Keeping it strategic.
Now heading home.
Just finishing up
watching episode 122
as we're doing 123.
I'm gonna bang out the next
minute and two seconds of this
then I might go Instagram Live.
I don't know, Tyler.
Just trying to think about
what to talk about today.
Maybe I'll talk about what
you guys want to talk about so,
give me a second.
I'm forcing DRock to
be in the episode.
Good week ahead,
actually, you know what?
Why don't we do this?
As I struggle to try to find
what I'm going to be
able to do on weekends.
Obviously, as we made this
commitment to do the show every
day on the weekends a lot of
it's going to be me and selfie
and obviously Tyler,
thanks for being here,
Other Tyler.
Thanks for being
here and filming.
I appreciate schlupping you
out of your Sunday but one thing
that I'll do as a series maybe
is how about the
week ahead highlights?
That's kind of cool.
So I can set up something
and then read it
so let's do a little thing.
Week ahead Monday,
seeing a former employee.
Got a great
agency now, she's killing it.
Seeing our GE client
which I'm excited about.
Seeing my Chief
Creative Officer, Steve.
Gonna jam with him discussing
some new business then heading
down to the Philly area
for a big business meeting.
Huge one.
Coming back some
internal meetings.
A book meeting
around Crushed It!
So more on that to come and
then Knicks game
against the Pelicans
and have a really fun
friend joining me for that.
So that's Monday.
Tuesday fly at
7 A.M. to Orlando.
I have an important call
with a client from Quaker.
Then, I speak in Orlando at
the ICR Summit, conference
where a lot of people get
together for the banking world,
the private equity world
and the brand world.
I like to talk about
the state of the union
of what's going on in there.
Then I fly back so I'll be
in Orlando for six hours.
Then I land, go to a meeting
with her Chief Creative Officer
and Facebook.
Then I have a dinner
with Jewel, the artist.
(Other Tyler laughs)
Yeah.
And then I catch up with
Phil about Vayner Capital.
Wednesday, client meeting.
6 A.M. workout,
client meeting 9 A.M.,
big one for two hours.
Then I go to the studio.
Which is in our
old office at 315.
So you guys will see that again
for the first time in a while
and then an internal call.
Doo-doo-doo.
Then Jay Williams, the
great Duke basketball player,
amazing entrepreneur.
Some internal stuff and a
investment meeting then a
surprise guest will be stopping
by from the music world.
I'm gonna save that and
not telling you guys that.
Then a internal meeting with
one of my favorite employees,
emerging superstar.
Thursday, early workout.
I'm speaking at a
school, actually.
Then I will be on
"The Breakfast Club."
So I'm making my next appearance
of "The Breakfast Club"
on Thursday.
Be ready for that.
Fired up about that.
Some internal meetings,
a lot of internal meetings.
A lot of internal meetings.
More internal meetings.
It's a hodgepodge
of internal meetings.
Clients, friends, investments.
A lot of that then
dinner, two dinners.
Two important dinners.
One for our consulting arm and
one for somebody else that
I can't talk about just yet.
Then I'm going to a client
Friday morning in Jersey.
Bunch of internal meetings.
VaynerMedia,
VaynerMedia, VaynerMedia,
VaynerMedia then
Friday night dinner
and then maybe after that
weekend, family time.
Martin Luther King Day.
Little hustle.
Little Knicks basketball.
So good.
That's the week ahead.
You got some previews,
leave in comments anything
you guys want for us to do.
You just saw in the last episode
we were talking a lot about
the ear, the listening,
the comments on Facebook,
Instagram, YouTube
are imperative and
they're all equal.
Just giving love like I love the
show or DRock you crushed it or
Tyler I love the way you edit.
Means so much to us.
It's fuel but then also details
like oh I liked that or
can expand more on that.
The feedback loop of
this is incredible. Right?
Now, I think we'll go to a
little bit of a a livestream.
So everybody on Instagram's
about to get real happy.
Which I love.
Three, two, one, blastoff.
What up, Instagram?
Happy Sunday, Sunday afternoon
sure some of you
are watching football.
I will not be doing that 'cause
I'm bitter and so only if I go
to the Super Bowl on business
will I be seeing any football.
Caught one second the Steelers
Dolphins game just as I was
filming some stuff right now.
Good to see you, Brandon.
Good to see you.
What up, what up, what up?
Big up's Ian
McKenzieball, good to see.
Ask your question, go.
I'm ready to answer it.
That's exactly what's
going on right now.
Other Tyler Babin is in the
house filming episode 123.
- [Other Tyler] 123.
- Which we will
have up tomorrow.
Yeah, the Knicks
jacket is legit.
Looking for your questions.
How to retain good talent?
Rohit, only one way, my
friends, to keep good talent,
communication.
Just gotta know.
Tyler's great talent,
really talented.
I think, you know, I think
you're super talented and all
I need to do is make him feel
safe to ask me if he wants more
challenges, more money,
different opportunities if he
sees VaynerTalent people are
traveling a lot and if that's
what right now he's
happy about my content, right?
But maybe he wants to like,
you just have to communicate.
Life changes ups and downs,
ebbs and flows.
What you have to do is
if you have great talent,
you have to remind
them on the macro,
the value you're actually
bringing them 'cause especially
with youth, you get
very impatient real fast.
And so, but I think I'm winning
that game more and more because
people seeing how different
career paths happen within the
org if they buy into that
patience but it comes down to
communication my friend, Rohit.
Like, just communicate.
Like the problem is most of
you don't want to ask the talent
what they want because you
don't want to give it to them.
it's being able to deliver on
what they want and having the
humility and the honor
and the empathy
to let that bird fly if
you're unable to feed it.
Luckily for me, I got so much
fucking feeder in my backpack
I got enough feeder for the
fucking world which is why I'm
not scared to communicate.
Like that analogy? (laughs)
Alright.
How do I conquer
the fear of failure?
A little bit over my
pay grade, Robert.
I think it's individual but
I do think fear is predicated on
caring about what other
people think and/or your own
self-esteem and
your own self worth.
Since I think I'm the best
and love myself the most and
I genuinely don't care what
anybody says though I appreciate
it and empathetic and take into
account what everybody says
I'm able to be fearless
when it comes to business.
When I was a teenager,
early 20s I wouldn't hit on some
girls that I liked because I was
fearful that my friends would
make fun of me for losing.
That's why I wasn't 100% fearful
in that and I wish in hindsight
I was 100% fearless in that
world too because that would've
been fun too, so you
know, that's the key.
It's feeling
great about yourself.
D Rose, how do
I remain motivated?
Listen, we've covered this so
much but Tyler cut this into
this one 'cause
it's always important and
there's always new people.
400 trillion to 1, not realizing
that you won
the lotto being a person.
Not realizing that
you have it so good.
I stay motivated
through gratitude.
Gratitude is the secret drug.
It is the gateway drug
to the motivation drug.
So many of you when
you first encounter me,
I read the comments
coke head, what drugs he on,
this and that you just don't
realize what purity of utter
happiness looks like and when
you are grateful that leads to
motivation, that leads
to the hyper nature.
Of course there's certain
chemicals with inside of me that
gave me a lot of energy and
things of that nature but
gratitude is absolutely
the beast that
drives my motivation
and excitement.
Want to squeeze every
single thing out of this life.
Want to squeeze every ounce
out of this life 'cause it's the
only one I've got.
My big thing is that I genuinely
don't think most things matter
and so I'm very big on
lack of ego is why
I'm good at delegating.
I actually think way too many
people suck at delegating 'cause
they're egotistical and they don't
deploy enough humility and they
actually are micromanaging
out of their own insecurities.
And so, it's very easy
for me to delegate because
I trust people
and I trust them upfront.
My dad always says you got to
earn my trust and I always say
I'm giving you trust and you
gotta lose it and actually it's
kinda hard to lose.
I think that's
allowed me to go fast.
It's allowed me to scale.
I think it's a differentiator
and I don't think anything can
really cripple me and
so I give them the room.
I think delegation has a lot to
do with ego and insecurities and
I watch and I'm able to do a lot
of things by giving people room.
And to me, if I'm doing 97
things and 97 people are helping
me and they're all ranging from
if a 10 was perfect execution
from a 4.2 to a 9.7
doing 97 things,
from a 4.2 to a 9.7 is a
hell of a lot better than doing
one or two things at a 10.0.
It's a net score game and that's
how I'm wired and that's how
I strategize and then as people
prove that they can do 9.2,
8.7 work I move them up and
if they prove they can do 11.0
work, I remind them that they
maybe should be doing something
for themselves so
that's the bottom line.
That's how I think about it.
So, I love yard sales and
garages sales 'cause
I love the thrill of the hunt.
It's the one place where you can
buy something for a dollar and
sell it for 90 and
you can do that four,
five, six times a Saturday
and and so I'm a big fan.
I'm watching so many of you
do the $20,170
eBay flip challenges
and it's not just eBay.
You know, it's, for clarity,
let's get this in the episode.
Let Go and Facebook Marketplace
seems to be crushing it for a
lot of people trying to sell
premium things like sneakers.
Craigslist, Etsy, you know
buying stuff and kind of like,
Tyler feel like you'd be good at
Etsy because you got that kind
of Brooklyn
creative thing going on.
I wouldn't be as good at Etsy
'cause I'm just not that cool or
creative but like I feel like
somebody who's really got that
artistic vibe can go garage
saling and understand what would
play as hipster and buy
something for a dollar just
really repackage it
and sell for $30 on Etsy
instead of $4 on eBay.
eBay's like a store,
eBay is like Walmart
whereas Etsy's like
that cool shop in, you know,
in Greenpoint
that you know you can
charge a whole lot more for even
though it's the same thing so
it's marketplace dynamics.
The more you guys become
educated it's no different than
the way I trade attention.
What's underpriced,
what's overpriced.
Instagram underpriced right now.
As you can tell
I'm going all in.
What's overpriced?
Tumblr, Tumblr's overpriced.
It's not a good place
to use my time when
I say priced right now.
Not the ad units so once you
understand what's underpriced
and overpriced on Etsy,
on Facebook Marketplace,
on eBay, on Craigslist, on
Let Go on all these different
new apps that sell and once you
understand what's underpriced
and overpriced at
TJ Maxx, Marshall's,
the Dollar Store,
Five Below and Goodwill,
other thrift stores,
and flea markets, which I don't
love, and yard sales
and garage sales,
town-wide sale.
When you Google from March to
October town-wide garage sale
when you can get 30, 40, 50,
60 garage sales in a two hour
period, you can clean house.
I'm watching people,
by the way, for clarity,
let's get this in here as well.
It is a $20,170 profit game.
You gotta make profit.
What kind if you think this is?
You can make
$20,170 and lose money.
There's no use in that.
Alright, by the way though, it's
been an explosion on Twitter.
Have you seen it?
Like, just an
explosion on Twitter.
Oh my God, did you see that our
theme song to the DailyVee was
used by the NFL today?
- [Other Tyler] So fast. Crazy.
- Crazy.
Anyway.
I'm in the
protein food business.
My product costs $9.50,
I'm trying to decide whether
to sell between 30 or 40.
What do you think?
Moe, I would really look at
the competitive landscape.
If all your competitors are
selling their product for 40 and
that's the range then
I'd probably go 37.
I think people are stunningly
naive about price mattering.
Everybody likes to
talk about, you know,
my product is so good this
and that but price is a factor.
It's one of the core pillars in
society so I always like to have
a little bit of a
competitive advantage on price.
That's how I built Wine Library.
It's how I built VaynerMedia.
It's how I built
my speaking career.
I eat my own dog food.
I'll go free from the beginning.
If I don't have leverage,
my shit is free.
So many of you are fancy.
So many of you are
fancy right now.
You think you're
great filmmaker.
You're a great filmmaker, great.
Let the market then pay for you.
Like, the market is the market.
Doesn't matter what you and your
best friend from college think.
It matters what the market
thinks and so every time I think
about pricing, I think about
how much leverage do I have.
If nobody knows who
I am and, by the way,
I've done this every
time I got into new genres.
I was really successful as a
wine retailer but nobody knew me
as a marketing agency so
I gave that shit away.
Too many fancy fuckers
coming out the gate.
Alright, I'm gonna catch up on a
little work before
I walk in to the house.
Hope you guys
have a great Sunday.
Think we got plenty
of content for you and
I will talk to you guys later.
And I appreciate the love.
I appreciate the word of mouth.
Before I sign off
so many of you,
the amount of people that are
screen shooting these live feeds
and then posting it on Instagram
and tagging me and giving me a
shout out and trying to
get friends to follow me
means the world to me.
Means so much to me.
I really appreciate it and the
word of mouth is the best way
you can pay back
the free content,
I do appreciate that.
It means a lot to me.
More than you think.
It's not so much that I get
four followers from your post,
it's that you care enough about
me to post it as one of your
Instagram posts.
Love you guys.
Hey, how's it going?
Really good.
Busy.
Yeah, I just landed.
Yeah.
So, how you doin'?
Mhmmm.
Winer-chuk.
Alright guys, have a good day.
We'll see you later.
The key of retaining
talent is not only asking,